[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
oui bonsoir
qu'est ce qu'on risque à parler à un
inconnu dans la rue qu'est ce qu'on
risque à dire non à un proche
qu'est ce qu'on risque à négocier une
augmentation de salaire qu'est ce qu'on
risque à se remettre en question qu'est
ce qu'on risque a changé ses habitudes
qu'est ce qu'on risque à regarder la
vérité par le prisme de quelqu'un
d'autre
toutes ces choses on essaye de risques
et on prend des risques on ose qu'est ce
qu'on risque a osé toutes ces choses
qu'est ce qu'on risque a osé en fait
l'audace qui est la capacité à oser
c'est pas forcément une compétence une
faculté qu on utilise souvent on n'ose
pas toujours en hausse peu je vais
d'abord vous poser une question va voir
justement qui parmi vous alors levé la
main qui parmi vous à oser quelque chose
à tenter quelque chose d'audacieux cours
du mois de mai lever la main
ok le osé lever la main ok super ok cool
alors qui parmi vous à oser quelque
chose cette semaine beaucoup ok qui a
osé quelque chose aujourd'hui levé la
main qui sont les heureux vainqueurs oui
mais les speakers ça compte pas sa coupe
c'est de la triche en fait en fait on
ose peu il ya plusieurs raisons à ça et
c'est normal la première raison pour
laquelle on n'ose peu c'est lui en fait
le cerveau c'est une super machine qui
nous vient comme on l'a vu tout à
l'heure de la préhistoire notamment le
cerveau reptilien qui en fait lui va
chercher en permanence à nous éviter le
danger c'est lui qui va assurer notre
survie en oisans nous
il en allait tenter et osé des choses
qui en fait reste dans notre zone de
confort
il va chercher à éviter le danger
il va chercher à faire et à reproduire
les choses qu'on sait déjà faire
finalement à rester dans nos habitudes
parce que le cerveau en fait ils
fonctionnent à l'efficacité énergétique
il veut faire les choses en dépensant le
moins d'énergie possible pour ça refaire
des choses qu'on connaît déjà agir dans
les situations qu'on connaît déjà rester
dans nos habitudes
donc le cerveau c'est une des raisons
pour lesquelles on ose peu c'est pas
facile de lutter contre lui la deuxième
raison c'est la peur de l'échec
c'est la peur de se planter de rater
deux loupés de faire une erreur
j'ai fait une erreur et c'est une raison
qui est assez culturel aussi parce que
la peur de l'échec
elle varie elle est différente par
rapport à la culture en france on n'a
pas une culture où l'échec est forcément
valoriser contrairement à des cultures
comme des pays anglo saxons les pays
nordiques par exemple en france on a
souvent entendu quand on était petit peu
mieux faire là où d'autres pays ils vont
plutôt dire tu es capable en france
l'erreur est pointée du doigt et même
parfois entouré en rouge souligné deux
fois dans une copie c'est un par là
quelques-uns il ya une étude pisa qui
explique donc l'étude pisa rond va dire
juge la performance éducative des
différents pays européens
en fait qui révèle que la france c'est
le pays où la peur de l'erreur la peur
de faire une erreur est la plus élevée
un des plus élevés donc en france oui
effectivement
l'erreur est pointé du doigt quelqu'un
qui se trompe qui connaît un échec
il est coupable il n'a pas assez
travaillé il est un peu un incompétent
là où dans d'autres pays on dira qu'il
aura été audacieux qui l'attend et qu'il
a osé
donc oui en fait la peur de l'échec
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles on
n'ose pas toujours mais pourtant on est
des serial loser
pourtant on a tous connu des échecs
souvenez vous c'est un peu loin mais
souvenez vous il ya une étude qui dit
qu' un enfant pour apprendre à marcher
ils tondent environ deux mille fois
c'est 2000 échec avant d'y arriver et on
a tous réussi ça appuie apprendre à
faire du vélo etc
donc en fait on a déjà échoué on a cette
culture de l'échec mais à un moment
donné où on oublie et puis on a peur du
jugement et on a peur de l'échec de
l'erreur et pourtant on est tous des
serial loser
j'ai un bon ami qui me dit que l'erreur
est humaine
je dis oui l'erreur est humaine d'accord
mais qu'est ce que ça signifie quand on
entend ça ça veut pas dire c'est pas
grave ça vive
en fait j'ai compris que quand on dit
l'erreur est humaine
ça veut dire que pour nous les hommes
les humains l'erreur c'est notre manière
d'apprendre ni les robots ni les animaux
n'apprennent grâce à leur échec grâce à
leurs erreurs labiche se fait toujours à
voir tout le temps par le lien tout le
temps et là on est là mais c'est pas
possible et nous eh bien nous on apprend
de nos erreurs de nos échecs en fait
l'échec c'est une belle source
d'innovation de découverte de créativité
christophe colomb il pensait aller en
chine quand il a découvert les amériques
professeur kellogg qui a oublié par
erreur du blé en train de bouillir puis
qu'il a laissé refroidir ce qu'il est
parti faire autre chose qui a inventé
les kellogg's serial qu'on mange tout le
temps mais ce spencer qui travaillait
dans une usine de colle et qui m'a par
erreur se trompe dans le dosage et
invente une colle qui ne colle pas balou
et pourtant on utilise ces post it tous
les jours donc oui en fait l'échec c'est
un bon moyen d'apprendre mais si je suis
ici aujourd'hui c'est pas simplement
pour vous dire allez-y
il plante et vous non si je suis là
c'est aussi pour vous dire que quand on
ose on peut rater on peut avoir un échec
est donc à prendre mais on peut et
surtout réussir qu'est ce qu'on risque a
osé le succès un succès qui va vous
renforcer dans votre confiance qui va
vous donner envie d'oser plus encore une
fois nelson mandela disait bon ami à moi
qui disais quand jose soit je gagne soit
j'apprends et c'est ça en fait parce que
finalement osé c'est une dynamique aux
essais pas simplement réservé à mandela
ou aux grands scientifiques aux grands
artistes de ce monde si je suis ici
c'est pour vous dire que c'est pour nous
vous moi tous c'est pour tout le monde
on peut tous osé mais pas des grandes
choses forcément ça peut être des
petites choses des choses du quotidien
des choses pour vous autour de vous aux
essais une dynamique c'est faire un pas
essayer avancé il continué pour moi
cette dynamique elle a commencé en 2015
n'arrivant à lyon j'ai eu une période
d'un an le chômage période d'un an plein
de doutes
j'ai trouvé un boulot cdi un cdi sauf
que ça me plaisait pas j'étais
malheureux j'étais pas épanoui l'âge et
enclencher la dynamique
j'ai osé quitter mon job parce que
j'étais malheureux et parce que cela
m'épanouit sais pas quelques jours après
j'ai osé traverser la france pour aller
à bordeaux dans une ville que je
connaissais pas vivre une expérience qui
s'appelle la fabrica déclic la fabrica
les clics c'est un festival citoyen qui
rassemble des jeunes en quête de sens
enquête de place dans la société et
aussi en quête d'eux mêmes
et là j'ai osé j'ai osé parler de mes
peurs de mes faiblesses
j'ai aussi oser parler de mes rêves et
la dynamique a continué quelques jours
après la fabrica déclic j'ai osé appeler
les organisateurs pour leur dire combien
ça m'avait bouleversé
sam avait transformé
encore un peu
ray ce déclic a continué m'a donné
l'énergie
j'ai osé me lancer le défi d'organiser à
lyon une première fabrique à déclic à
l'été 2016 sans réseau sans argent et
puis un déclic entraînant une confiance
entraînant un succès je me suis dit mais
pourquoi pas j'ai osé gravir le mont
blanc alors que j'ai une trouille du
vide pas possible et que j'avais jamais
fait d'alpinisme et puis en 2017
j'ai continué à oser je me suis fait des
tatouages
non c'est pas vrai
en 2017 j'ai osé avoir un enfant alors
que j'avais une trouille bleue de
devenir père est en fait cette dynamique
quand on enclenche elle vous porte et ça
continue et en fait juste après ça ben
j'ai eu le courage et j'ai continué
d'oser jusqu'à être jusqu ici devant
vous à ce tedx pour vous parler de ça
j'ai osé être là devant vous il en faut
du courage
tout ça pour vous dire que je suis
persuadé qu en osant on peut lancer
cette dynamique
alors je vais vous faire une proposition
et si on osait ensemble ici et
maintenant je vais vous inviter à fermer
les yeux en vous posant cette question
allez-y fermer les yeux et posez vous
cette question
qu'aimeriez-vous avoir osé dans une
semaine
d'accord on est le week-end prochain
qu'aimeriez-vous avoir osé vous
visualisez bien l'action l'activité le
lieu voilà ancrer le bien dans votre
esprit et quand vous l'avez vous pouvez
ouvrir les yeux et je vais vous inviter
à partager ce que vous aimeriez osé dans
une semaine en une phrase avec votre
voisin ou votre voisine donc allez-y
partager avec votre voisin voisine ce
que vous aimeriez osé
ok
alors vous avez tous partager ce que
vous aimeriez aux est super alors on va
continuer on va voir si on peut aller un
peu plus loin dans cette dynamique puis
on va essayer d'oser quelque chose
ensemble
c'est ça vous va je vais vous inviter à
tous vous lever voyez encore il y en a
qui se sont tenus la main je sais alors
allez-y levé vous détendez vous un peu
les jambes
alors je sais que vous êtes tenu la main
tout à l'heure si ça vous va on va
essayer d'aller encore un cran plus loin
et on va essayer tous ensemble de faire
ce qu'on adore tous faire passer à
l'autre truc si ça vous va on va oser
ici et maintenant on va tenter on verra
bien ce que ça donne de rire tous
ensemble d'accords donc on va se laisser
30 secondes pour simplement rire tous
ensemble on verra bien
au début si ça vient pas vous forcer un
peu et puis vous regardez autour de vous
et puis on généralement ça marche ok on
y va aller ok bon bah fallait le tenter
un
ok merci merci cool en fait je voulais
aussi expérimenté ça parce que pour vous
dire aussi qu'on pouvait oser
on pouvait oser et que aux essais
pouvait être pas forcément se prendre
trop au sérieux et on n'est pas obligé
d'oser des choses graves en fait moi ce
que je vais vous dire c'est que je suis
persuadé que aux essais une dynamique et
que quand on s'engage dans la voie où on
se dit que tous les jours on aimerait
tenter une chose de plus nouvelle va
forcément des grandes choses ça nous
ouvre des portes
il a une phrase qu'on connaît tous qui
dit la chance sourit aux audacieux
ouais je pense que je crois ça parce que
quand on ose il ya des perspectives
nouvelles qui s'ouvrent
il ya des opportunités qui viennent à
nous l'audace est contagieuse
l'audace désert entraîne l'audace des
autres
si vous osez plus un petit peu chaque
jour si vous tenter plus de choses si
vous essayer plus de choses les gens
autour de vous vont avoir envie de faire
pareil
ce qu'ils vont porter un regard positif
sur vous moi je suis persuadé qu'on
pourra changer les choses si on ose plus
si chacun d'entre nous aux un peu plus
c'est un peu plus audacieux
alors on fera émerger une génération de
personnes
audacieux ancrée connectés à leur wake
up call jeu persuadé que si vous vous
affronter des problèmes des
questionnements en osant vous trouverez
des solutions donc face aux problèmes et
aux défis de demain
oser lever voué aux et au pire ça marche
merci
[Applaudissements]